we blocked out the shoot dates we
blocked out the post-production this is
before we even started writing any of
the screenplays so we'd already had a
whole plan in place
what were the steps you went through
from being an actor to becoming now a
storyteller screenwriter what changed
did anything really change
a lot has changed um
and i'd say for the better
um as
i felt
what's the word
just being an actor i never felt very
secure because i felt as i said earlier
always at the mercy of opportunities
coming to me and being cast
whereas um
you know
writing a screenplay and being a
director you're taking control of your
career
um and it was really hard to get there
but um
i just really
knew
that
the story that i wanted to get behind
was something that should be out there
and um it was very challenging getting
the investors and the
putting it all together because i wore
many hats in this one i was a producer
director writer actor
i even made lunch at times i was even a
gaffer what i had to be you know i did
everything i even cleaned the toilets
when they backed up i was i mean
literally i did it all um
but i just felt that
you know it was my first project and you
know not people weren't making that much
money so whatever i could do to make it
better for everyone i did
um
i believe we're all equal on a film set
you know the right with the runners no
different i would listen to them all and
i think that i tried to create a very
like comfortable
happy environment where people could
shine
in any everything they were doing every
i wanted every department to shine and
it was quite hard for me at first to
navigate that because i didn't
necessarily know
what every department was supposed to be
doing so i had to kind of learn very
quickly because you need the ship to be
seamless you need to run it and you need
to know what everyone's doing so that
kind of took me a little time to figure
out i'm still figuring that out because
it's very detailed and um
but i think that
having respect for everyone and like
really letting them
do their job
is important
so having the knowledge of being an
actor and being on set for so many years
as an actor as a dancer
you know i i kind of was always watching
as i said before i'm a very inquisitive
person so i was always even when i was
acting or dancing on sets i was always
interested what everyone was doing
and then when you're a director it's
your job to know what everyone's doing
because if someone's not doing their job
properly you need to
make sure they are
so
it's a difficult role sometimes because
you're
you know
you'll sometimes have people that have
different opinions
um but at the end of the day it's your
vision
and you need to come from a place of
love and
make express that
and that's one thing else i've i've
learned how to express from your heart
rather than
say this is wrong if you can really
inspire with your word it's going to be
so much better
right and especially when you're in a
high pressure situation like you have to
make your day
and you only have so many days left and
certain pages of the script haven't been
covered and things like that i'm sure
it's
it's harder to come from your heart in
those moments
but yeah what makes your writing process
different than others
having a background in um
dancing and um performing
having that kind of
uh
detailed
um regime where you're literally in the
studio
as a dancer you're in the studio at 8am
you're leaving at 8pm it's a really hard
schedule
so
i always knew
what you had to have a work ethic to be
a dancer or be a professional performer
you can't just phone it in so i kind of
applied that to when i became when i
started my endeavors as a writer
i made sure
i took it really seriously i blocked off
you know two or three months
five days a week i treated it like a job
if you treat it like a job as a job
i i didn't treat it like a hobby i i
knew um
with the sure process i actually speak
to a life coach
so before we even i just i told her the
whole thing and she said well how are
you going to make this movie so we
actually planned the whole year
um from we blocked out how long it would
take to write the script we blocked out
time to raise investment we blocked out
the pre-production we blocked out the
shoot dates we blocked out the
post-production this is before we even
started writing any of the screenplays
so we'd already had a whole plan in
place
so and then we actually stuck to it and
literally everything
happened and if it hadn't if we i think
having that full plan
um
really helped stick to a schedule
because otherwise you could be writing a
script for a year and then you know how
long is a piece of string and then it's
just one of these things that's just a
never-ending thing so i think having an
end goal and having a real schedule
having a plan
then you can execute the plan you can
hold yourself accountable to the plan
um and i think i mean i treat that
with everything i do i try and have a
whole
game plan in place
of how i'm gonna do it
so you had a life coach
help you plan out a film about
not so much life coaches but gurus um
interesting that's fascinating my life
coach in fact um is an amazing woman
sarah alexander who in fact is a story
consultant on the shuri process because
she's been
to a lot of the retreats and she has
first-hand experience
with subject matter so she was actually
very very helpful in me creating the
beats to the screenplay before writing
the screenplay she helped me understand
the types of characters that would go
there why they would go there and she
actually experienced a lot of the things
that occurred over the weekend
so yeah it was really helpful having a
consultant that really knew
the world more than i did
and then she helped me just really stay
on track
and i think you know it's
having a real plan
will make it so much easier to navigate
if you don't really have a plan
then it's harder to kind of you know
know where you're at so i think whatever
project you do
it's really good to have like an idea of
how you're going to execute it and who
you want to involve yourself with and
the timeline of how to how to do it
did she give you homework and say when
you come back to me
we need to have this done
she gives me a lot of homework actually
it's really challenging talking to her
because she really pushes me she you
know every we speak once we still
actually we still work together we're
working together right now we're working
on some other projects um
and uh
it's exhausting she really pushes me um
she asked me questions that i have like
a very in-depth
profound things i hadn't really thought
about and challenges me to like
understand the purpose of why people
should be watching this and why i should
be telling this story
um and it's been really helpful i think
everyone should have someone whether
it's a life coach or or someone that can
that can believe in them inspire them
also push them
it's great to have that figure in your
life i think
right and so you would come back with
completed pages and would you actually
review them with her um so she lives in
the uk um and it was funny so we've been
working together for four years we
actually did trophy boy together
um
she's actually been one of the most
instrumental people in my
becoming this director of coming
this this new journey i'm going on she's
one of the people that's really helped
me
navigate it and see how i can do it um
but yeah so i'd send her pages weekly
and she would give me her notes and um
she was very involved with as well with
the
screenplay and the edit of the movie
and now since the release that's now the
release we're talking about like you
know pr ideas and marketing so it's been
really cool been really interesting
so she saw the rough cut won your editor
she saw every graph cut said she saw
probably like ten cuts yeah
fascinating
that's that's actually great really
grateful to her yeah to have a coach
that's kind of holding you accountable
in some way you know like a sponsor or
something almost but yeah but not maybe
in the same vein but and she really
wants the film to you know
whilst fame money and acclaim are great
i just really want the audience to
emotionally connect to the film and come
away with something and that's what we
we we really like fine tune
what is the intention for the audience
to come away with why should they invest
an hour and a half of their life in
the project so
those key questions are things that i
think every filmmaker should ask
themselves when they're making a film
or a show you know why is the audience
watching it
well sure and i think what i came away
with is about trust and it's not just
about
trusting
someone else to help you about trusting
yourself as new age as that sounds but
you know because there are moments where
declan asks a lot from these
participants
and and they trust in him and then
i think
trusting in yourself was probably the
biggest lesson
yeah yeah awesome i'm glad you got that
yeah and stripping away
the mask and the onion and getting to
the core of you is actually where
healing can begin
right i like the one character forgive
me um his name wasn't mark was it it was
the one that who was taking care of his
mother monk okay mark um
yeah i liked him because you know he was
so quiet and you knew there was
something very deep
brewing and he was kind of off to the
side
a lot of the time i know the main
character was too but
he wouldn't let people in and and i
think there was something very
interesting you knew that there was a
lot of
some deep waters in there i guess for
lack of a better term i'm glad that you
saw that yeah
it's not what he's saying it's how
you're seeing you show not tell
so that was kind of the goal with mark
so i'm glad you felt that thank you